[Music]
in are you serious news submitted by
Californication a teen was sentenced to
life in prison for strangling his sister
over the Wi-Fi password yeah dude this
is the kind of [ __ ] where when you're
growing up this makes me want to
strangle this guy yeah I kind of feel
this guy though like if someone doesn't
give you Wi-Fi a password and you got I
mean you're talking to your online
girlfriend or your look in the middle of
the game and [ __ ] cuts and it's like
she changed the password that's some
death [ __ ] right there I've been there
too really when you share an Internet
when you're a kid because people
internet gets lowered the more people
using it but your parents are painful I
don't know what's that privilege so
growing up just the difference a kid now
if a kid now did that I mean I'd slap
the [ __ ] out oh well yeah well yeah you
wouldn't vote I'm saying is like the
internet now is a hundred times faster
than it was when we were growing up true
like then kids now don't know what
dial-up this may be they're achieving
its Lois we don't have the modems
- did he kill his sister unfortunately
yes Wow he strangled her I mean how so
this is in Georgia he's 18 years old and
he strangled his sister to death
true and he got a light life in prison
for that I mean he definitely he did get
a life life in prison see he got little
possible well he got life in prison but
the other mom that story it's all good
so yeah he got life in prison
so compete keV on is his name he's from
Georgia he have um changed the Wi-Fi
password so that his sister couldn't
clog the internet while he's playing
video games cuz it was slow down the
internet apparently he doesn't have the
best internet I was like he said I'm
[ __ ] can you can do everything now you
could play ten games online when you're
five
what was the speed let's ask he change
the password on her and she changed it
back to something different so he
changed the password on her and then she
was able to change it HAMB she's a
hacker she's good she's good
oh she just figured out
Oh girlfriends girlfriends name what's
it what's your favorite how is she she
was 20 she's older damn is grown-ups
older sister 18 and 22 choke each other
over the waii my mind I saw 8 9 year
olds choking each other out that's what
I thought it was good yeah oh yeah well
high school kids so they got into a
scuffle they hit the ground mom called
the cops but it was too late he put her
in a chokehold and held her there for 15
minutes why didn't mom break it up oh
damn what is this guy have so much
violent tendencies a mom scare me think
of something like that I mean it's got
to be 30 minutes if you're putting your
sister in a choke hold for 15 minutes
he only released her when deputies
stormed the house and ordered him to bro
wait so she was already dead yes she was
dead in his arm yes
did they hope that maybe she was passed
out but how do you think somebody might
choking them is a very intimate way of
killing though race yeah what is it race
weight wagers race everyone good I know
what it is you are Joe violence like
this [ __ ] I think it's white because
white people yeah I know what it is so I
can't say what it is I don't think race
has anything to do with it and that's
one because it's kind of like I think
he's Cambodian it could be Cambodia what
are you doing it very dark Asian yes
this is the guy he might be from Africa
Africa they're black they might not be a
like them it could be you know the
Dominica ain't gonna be like America -
last names Fernandez they're half white
any no they're black you don't
understand and this this goes also the
police brutality things why does he look
like a broccoli this whole like
chokehold thing is you know not it
doesn't hurt people the chokehold is
meant to choke people to death well but
I guess Lina you're not a little wet
like WWE long - yeah choking someone to
death is really intimate man like you
feel the [ __ ]
there when they go a lifeless yeah you
hope it's a sleeper hold you hope yeah
yeah but you know cuz they push on the
down the trachea and they break it what
they don't know is you're putting a
sleeper hold
you got a squeeze on the side to cut
that blood flow while people don't know
that you push it yeah a lot of people
not trained they should teach them in
schools how to do it right I know you
think they teach at it like police
academy this is how you do these legal
chokehold so yeah so deputies perform
CPR trying to save her and then she was
declared dead at the hospital
oh yeah there's a point in May because
I'm trying to think like situations like
that is this the first thing people say
when a mass shooting is announced white
people he white is that yeah this is
pretty good we all have stereotypical
crimes right oh so like if you if you
think human smuggling you might think
Asian I did not I thought what is this
very typical Japanese because the
Japanese would be like yeah like selling
dirty underwear or like oh that's a lot
worse than like for us you know like
like like like yeah music you can
because I've taken I think of sex
traffickers as white guys like Eastern
Europeans yeah
cuz when I think choking somebody else
for Wi-Fi I don't think black I don't
think black yeah I think I think I think
high school white kids and that could
perhaps be because we're all [ __ ]
stupid with stereotypes true we're not
good FeO typical people or not no I
think I'm great cuz I built a career off
a stereotype I know I'll let you guess
what my crime is Indians
oh just brown people in general oh maybe
this is so no ending amongst brown
people in India or Indians in America
ah that's I don't think there's a
distinction which are tiring stuff I was
gonna say terrorists I was gonna say
really no Indian to scamming
that's the still yeah I think I thought
cuz they call call scam
are those like Nigerians I don't know
like to like hey you're having problem
with your computer guy
yeah it's like oh well if you pay me now
I can help you over the phone yeah but
that happens yo [ __ ] yeah it happens
that was yeah don't that was my
stereotype since this that is an Indian
Indian table bigger than terrorism come
on well I think as far as everyday
utility yeah maybe if you're from a
trailer but I will say this if you know
I'm Indian right you just assume like
everyone sees me up there from the
trailer park though if I lived in a
trailer park while I think dad Indians
terrorists I see you at the airport nice
to help me my laptop is broken yeah
we're at the airport cheap deal you feel
like you did all the time I'll fly you
know I have pre-check I have clear I'll
get it you know whatever upgrade to
first class just recently they're like
hey random check and I'm like oh yeah
all the time man
I get random check every time I go
really not kidding I get it every what
do you think they're profiling you for
with whatever a mass shooter mass
shooter mass shooter but now that's the
thing
but I'm actually surprised you guys
think that but it makes me feel a little
bit better than what cuz I'm Asian dude
like so I'm not I'm if I was a trailer
park dude like I probably think you know
you're a [ __ ] Middle Eastern guy or
whatever that's what it is right yeah
yeah but but but I'm saying like the
stereotypes that we know is different
look it's a crime stereotype right so
like I think what I think Indian I think
scam I think like human smuggling I
think like yeah you know why I think it
is what I think slums annually I think
it's because I get deals and when I pack
my bag and [ __ ] I don't necessarily get
all the lotions and all the things to be
exactly the sensory the three L's
probably do it that's true when you
think might people you think either
pedophilia or bombings or shootings the
Tim McVeigh [ __ ] kidnapping kidnapping
for sure do you use it that's not what
kind of white but let me ask you to do
white people have the stereos you know
stereo to blue drove like we caused all
mass shooting together and be like hey
guys like no you know guys like you get
if I get together with a bunch of you
know Indians we've obviously are like
yeah whatevs
yeah you love drone stereotypes but I
wonder if they have that realization yet
Oh about white people what I like that's
it there's a lot of white people out
there who like hey man that's not cool
say come on man what I realized is why
people don't have the same mentality as
us where the groupthink thing happens
they don't see they don't have that they
don't have the same thing we do do you
guys especially you you guys I don't
know you guys as well I'm hang with you
a bunch but these cats always bring race
into the conversation when I'm like I
don't even know where it could come they
don't think like that right I mean that
doesn't even come up to me like honestly
I grew up in almost like everyone was
white yeah we're in Westchester New York
it's like all Irish Catholic Italian
that's a different kind of white you'll
see race and when you're minority
growing up in a prevalent other
ethnicity like you'll you'll feel them
at the the racism man are you feeling in
the most subtle way yeah like they don't
even know like for example the school I
went to from a blast my school are in
mascots or Indians but the it's like
Native American Native Americans but
they're called Indians like we're
Mahopac Indians and today they go around
yeah yeah and so but Mahopac is actually
Native American word and so to me it's
like why our why's it called Mahopac
indians like everyone knows everyone
knows that they're not Indians yeah like
Christopher Columbus some white dude
just showed up and was like I'm an India
[ __ ] it right dude man friend that's
Chris for fun cool so it's like why is
it still there I don't know it doesn't
affect me directly but it's just like
simple things does Washington Redskins
affect you it doesn't affect me but do I
think it's racist absolutely
because we would never we would never
call a football team the Washington like
crackers
they'll be tight
oh dude it's because they bought Vikings
Vikings as crackers but no but they're
Vikings there it would be saying like
pirates or like a warrior clan you know
like that's why I like Kansas City
Chiefs it's not I don't think it's
really true because I'm saying it would
be like the Gurkhas shilling member you
know like the military [ __ ] yeah yes
be accurate
don't come Redskins if it was accurate
you own if they were called like the
Washington and whatever their tribe was
I'm not but like the what's a college
team the Seminoles right in Florida
that's the tribe for one last test
that's a communal thing yeah but that's
a culture they're not calling them like
the San Diego
you know savages yeah like you know what
I mean do you like San Diego human
sacrifice a sex like when's it or not
cause I think you know you mean imagine
if there was a high school that was
called like San Gabriel chinks or
something like that we are a different
breed of creatures but you know it's
just they yeah well she I wouldn't know
what that feels like cuz I grew up like
mainly with blacks and Mexicans and the
Asians we're still minorities all
minorities and in all the white kids
were like how it felt bad for them cuz
they're getting flogging bullied like
every day just for being white and then
I didn't realize there were so many
white people in this world until like
college or you know cuz then a different
outlook for it's different of course but
then there were I mean no matter what
there was still racism right because
like if you're a minority group and then
everybody else is like a different group
they're gonna [ __ ] bully you just for
whatever reason difference right yeah
yeah but that's crazy man I didn't I
didn't know that um that you guys grew
up in an all-white area it was just yeah
it was all way I personally after after
9/11 thinks we're weird I mean obviously
my personal friend group is everything's
fine
and I didn't really experience racism
but there was definitely like if they
people don't know us or like Oh
who's that right what's that you know
what are they doing here I remember I
went on a I think I told us last time I
wanted a marching band trip when I was
in eighth grade to Disney World and on
the way back with my high school I was
the only kid who was searched that's
[ __ ] up yeah the only kid and like
everyone's like a portable like alarm
clock dude I'd like my key my braces my
gameboy
you know II like yours did you think
that it was a little bit tight after
9/11 that now I want two rolls opened up
so that you could play positive and the
silver lining is that I will play the
villains you don't I mean you got work
that way get some residual checks going
let's get this thing but I've never
played terrorists yet okay hey man
Wolfie will they want one that we can
will maybe hook that up who's do it can
you guys write something